[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
we missed by a point last week that's
okay that is okay because it's NFL week
five and by that point I'm talking about
the parlay Sam so you know I had to brew
another
parlay for the people we're gonna hit it
real quick we're gonna hit it real quick
off the top let's pull it up let's pull
it up so I can show you guys
hey what's better than starting off a
show with the parlay Sam what's better
than starting off a show no better way
yeah there's no better way than starting
off a show with the parlay there it is
Sam Ryan I want you to dig in here too
we got Packers minus two and a half
they're on right now Ryan give us an
update of the score you got an update of
that score yeah it's 20 to 10 Packers
going into halftime
so that leg looks like it might be
checked I don't want to put any bad
vibes or any uh bad the bad vibes into
the atmosphere but if you guys want to
tell that pick it was an early game if
you guys want to tell take the lot take
take the live take the half time packers
should roll there uh we got buffalo
buffalo minus six and a half hold on
hold on hold on control room let's bring
that back so we can go through the
parlay there it is
the 49ers minus one the Kansas City
Chiefs minus two and a half and the
Chargers minus one look at those odds
plus 515 Ryan Sam I need a I need a tank
I I need a take
well I I don't want to give a tease but
you and I are going directly head to
head on one of my six bets and maybe my
first bet so I'll I'll save my take for
then and Ryan can give his kick
Chargers scare me Greg charger's scared
Chargers scare you against the Browns
it's sir I I smell a rat line I'm
smelling the cheese on this one but
listen again Vibes plus 515 this is the
juiciest one you've given us how do I
not how do I not ride I tried to make it
super juicy on this one okay enough with
this parlay though guys enough with this
parlay there is a game going on right
now Ryan you just gave us an update you
just gave us an update of the score
what's going on how's it looking how's
Aaron Rodgers we need some stats a
little a little uh how's Dobbs doing
how's my guy Dobbs doing I got him on my
fantasy team well I think right now the
the main guy right now is Alan Lazard
who's catching who's catching balls but
Aaron Rodgers has two touchdown passes I
think he hits his over I think is is
over under for passing touchdowns was
one and a half I personally have the
Packers minus eight I also have AJ Dylan
to score a touchdown so once again uh
today I have a touchdown score in a
London game that has not scored a
touchdown yet so uh but you hit it last
week I did after after we went off the
air Justin ran one in so maybe that's
the same thing I'd like to celebrate
with you guys though so let's get that
going maybe those are the Vibes but guys
that's enough let's get right to the
show because you guys know why we are
here that man that is in the middle Sam
Richmond he is the sharp of this show
he's been hot this whole year and he has
six Best Bets that we love that Isla I
don't know actually let me take that
back I don't know I love them yet I
don't know if I love them yet but
usually usually you know I'm riding with
my man Sam Richmond uh Ryan
hello sir thank you thank you for being
here uh I love your setup and I'm going
to say that every time every time until
I get that set up love the setup all
right here we go Sam let's get right to
it though you got 45 seconds on the
clock this week
45 seconds on the clock this week Sam
get right to it let's go
all right so I I teased it that you and
I would be going head to head on one
pick and we're starting off right off
the bat with it
um I have the Browns this week uh I hate
to go against you Greg let me let me
make my case for you
um the Browns offense has been sneaky
very very good this year
um I think the one thing obviously
they're known for doing and the thing
they do the best is run the ball and
that is pretty helpful against the
Chargers team who is kind of middle of
the pack bottom of the road uh defending
the run I know a lot has been made the
Browns defense has been pretty bad this
year I think their 30th overall dvoa
defensively this year but it's really
mostly been against the Run they haven't
been able to stop the run and that
doesn't really matter that much against
the Chargers who rank like 24th in Rush
raid and rushing dvoa so I think this is
a sneaky good matchup
Sam that is the time but uh I I know you
Sam I know the way you bet you like the
home dog that's the reasons I mean I I
gotta respect it I gotta respect it uh
let's move on to the second pick Sam you
gave us your first pick Cleveland plus
two it's locked in at the bottom of the
screen you guys can see it talk to us
about the second pick
so this is that I mean I'm sure all of
my picks the audience is gonna yell at
me and hate uh per usual this is the one
they're especially Gonna Hate we are
taking the commanders plus one and a
half this is the grossest pick on the
board
I don't mean to cut into your time I
thought that was 15. I'm sorry I'm sorry
you're good uh I I don't want to steal
your thunder with the parlay so I would
never never go in your territory and
take a plus 15. but yeah okay the
commanders stink I get it commenters
you're yelling at me they stink uh
Carson wins stinks they can't pass the
ball he's terrible the one thing they do
well is they stop the run and again you
gotta look at the matchups this matters
a lot against the Titans Team all they
want to do is run the ball the rush rate
is I want to think I want to say top
five they just want a candidate to
Derrick Henry all game long the
commanders can stop the run uh and force
Ryan Tannehill to beat them uh with the
banged up Titans receiving core that's
not very good to begin with I'm going
over the time you make Ryan Tannehill
beat me I'm not scared of that and yes
win stinks all right
I tried to I'm sorry for cutting you off
brother I tried to give you some time I
know I you cut me off that's your fault
we went over now I know
hey cut me some snack I know I know I
cut you off but brother you were just
going you were babbling you were going
and we're going and going and going but
it's okay I love the pick love to pick
uh we got two locked in let's talk to
Ryan producer Ryan come in here we need
some audience reactions how are they
feeling to my man Sam the shark
the audience has hot takes guys the
polar Stone
surprisingly on the brown side saying I
don't want the points though I want the
money line he's all over the Browns
money line uh right Regal superb says
you're lost if you think the commanders
win this game shaking my head we are
some and in all caps trash uh so it
doesn't really work I'm not saying they
don't stink but you know who also stinks
Ryan Tannehill and the Tennessee Titans
that that is fair no trailing Burks
today either uh that's a big deal it is
a big deal uh wavy Keith saying Jets and
lions I love the Jets today guys I love
the Jets uh I'm back on the Jets the
polo Stone back in here saying Lions
plus money commanders and lions seem
very popular in here we have another
chub anytime touchdown uh from Kenny
obelar uh trying to run back the
classics I get it it hit last week uh
but yeah a lot of lions talking here Sam
I'm hearing you have a take on this game
oh that's a that's a nice segue should I
just should I just roll right through it
let's let's roll right into it all right
yes
really good really good production
producing work by Ryan give that man a
raise
um I I'm on the Pats today uh I really
like the Pats today and to me this is
again football is all about matchups you
gotta look at the matchups I'm doing my
hand gestures the Pats are the best Rush
offense in the NFL and Greg Ryan can I
just have you guess who is the worst
Rush defense in the NFL
it is Detroit Lions it is the Detroit
Lions this is just a perfect matchup for
the Patriots they're going to run the
ball all game long producer Ryan I think
you could look this up the Detroit Lions
have allowed more points through four
weeks than any team in NFL history so
let that sink in before you go all in on
this line scene this defense is
historically bad the Pats know what they
want to do they want to run the ball
they want to play defense this matchup
sets up really nicely for them
yeah you are correct by the way they
have let up the most points in NFL
history through four games uh listen
dude I you you're never gonna get me to
take the New England Patriots minus
three with their what third string
quarterback is it Bailey Zappos it
doesn't matter they're just gonna like
Belichick is good at this he's not gonna
put him in bad spots or he's gonna have
to win the game they're just gonna hand
the ball off all game long and they're
gonna ball control they're gonna play
defense they're gonna run it down the
lion's throat uh uh it's it's not gonna
be the zappy show today all right I will
say I am unapologetically the biggest
Dan Campbell guy that has ever lived so
uh that that's where I stand from there
but uh give us your next pick all right
next pick also think uh well you're
gonna hate this one you're not gonna
like this one uh I am taking the
Dolphins minus three the Jets stink I
don't know who needs to hear this the
Jets not base stink
they're two and two let's look at their
wins a absolute Miracle onside kick
fluke win versus the Browns and then
they beat uh rest in peace to Greg's
preseason Futures parlay the worst team
in the league in the Steelers with a
rookie quarterback like their bottom 25
in both offensive and defensive
this team stinks the Dolphins have edges
literally everywhere in the field even
with their backup quarterback they
probably have an edge a quarterback I I
would almost I don't know if we have
time for it but I would actually love to
hear your pitch of the Jets Ryan or Greg
if you like that pick because I I just
do not see it I think this team stinks
clutch this out the Jets stink so Part
of Me Part of Me the reason for this
today is when I was driving into the
office today I drove by I was drive by
MetLife Stadium on my way in and I saw
it lit up in green and I said how how
could this not be the Jets today that
was part of it for me part of it is also
Zach Wilson I I just think last week I
gave him crap I was like I don't want to
bet on the Jets I don't know what it is
with Zach Wilson I like him I just I
like him I like Robert Salah I like
Garrett Wilson I think they have weapons
on offense I really do I I don't know
are we talking about the J the Jets
against the Jets the Jets seriously sir
Ryan you sound like a homer like I'm a
cowboy Greg all respects all respects to
Salah he came from the San Francisco
tree to respect he's a good coach I like
what he's doing out there but today
we're talking about today against this
Miami Dolphins team the Jets I just I
don't know about that one the Dolphins
are good three points exactly the
Dolphins are good they're solid they're
solid can you look up Ryan what Teddy
Bridgewater is against the spread in his
career because it is very very very good
uh and I think people need to know that
so you really just so we're clear you
only want me to pull up stats that fit
your agenda just over here okay this is
a hundred percent
uh and we're trying to connect Dots here
Ryan that's all we're trying to do we're
trying to connect dots and and get and
see wins
connect dots and see when okay it is an
unreal record he's 24-6 that's actually
pretty crazy
I didn't think it was gonna be very good
hey
Sam drop the mic and let's move on to
the next bit all right let's do it
um all right another one people are
gonna hate uh maybe we should just like
honestly maybe we should just change the
name of the show like six bets from Sam
that the audience is gonna hate maybe
that's that's the name of show but
um I like the Cardinals today uh again
I'll say this in the front end like I'm
not a Cardinals guy I kind of think they
stink I like the eagles I think the
Eagles are really good but uh just the
hype on this Eagles team is is getting
out of control and I know Ryan is going
to agree with me on that point uh it's
just inflated this line is too big five
points on the road is a lot uh again the
Cardinals haven't been very great this
year but one thing they do is they run
the ball pretty well Eagles can't stop
it very much they're also top five in
time of possession so I think if the
Cardinals can hold on to this ball at
home do a little ball control not get
take the ball out it hurts his hands uh
they can cover the Five Points at home
but look I get it it's a it's a it's a
gross play it's a classic disgusting
play Eagles have been great but can they
sustain that level of Excellence every
week the NFL just does not work like
that so I like Arizona today
I like it too I like it too uh Arizona's
at home right yep I think they're at
home yep I like that home salmon those
home dogs I told you guys earlier in
this show he likes them uh Ryan it's
time to bring you back onto the show and
let us know what the people in the
comments are talking about are they
giving us Good Vibes or are they sending
I don't even want to say it just just
give us just tell us what they're
talking about right well first off I
love I absolutely love the eagle slender
I think maybe if we want to just take
another 30 minutes to go do that I'm
down uh but my guy Zippy jumping in here
saying Titans commanders final score
will be 3-2 which is hilarious because
I'm all over the over in that game so I
you know I love that hey that's a that's
a that's a win for me Titans win 3-2 I
hit that plus one and a half I love it
yeah there you go
um
Alejandro Carrera Samuel love this he
says Sam has changed the way I bet he is
so analytical I love it you're changing
wow so you're only experience
let's send that guy a merch pack uh just
he's doing something nice about me and I
have a big ego
uh Vinnie eight seven saying too many
birds to pick from uh
I guess sure yeah there's a lot of birds
uh Mike uh M Kent 93 AJ Brown Easy Money
TD
DWI 22 says uh Eagles money line sea
bass says Cardinals we need to get rid
of the Eagles Vibes in this chat if you
like the eagles get out no I'm just
kidding but stop it stop it there it is
thank you or Ryan thank you guys in the
comments keep those comments coming uh
Sam we got two more to go one more one
more one more let's get right to it then
one more to go Sam talk to the people
all right this is I think this is my
favorite pick of the week this is the
Sunday night game I I've talked about
the Ravens on the show every single week
I absolutely love the Ravens I think
they are one of the elite teams in the
league they continue to not they their
price is a pretty good team I continue
to think they should be in that upper
echelon tier I get the record is two and
two it's not great but as we pointed out
in Social this week they only trailed
and four 14 total seconds in those two
losses like this team should be 4-0 yeah
the best passing offense in the league
for advanced analytics Lamar is on an
absolute war path uh the Bengals offense
has been sneaky pretty mediocre this
year bottom 20 and pass and Rush uh dvla
the line is still a mess great Revenge
spot for the Ravens after getting blown
out by the Bengals last uh last year
um I I think they win this game and I
would buy low on them to win the Super
Bowl if you have not placed a future on
them yet I think this team's amazing
future alert future alert if you guys
don't know my man Sam Richmond is the
man of the future he's the man that's
might be your last chance to get like a
really good number on them I'll just say
that because they they win this game
they take control of the division and
then they're probably going to be around
like plus 1200. so if you like the
Ravens tonight and you think they're a
good team I would also look at the
future
there it is man of the future my man Sam
does drop those future bets like no
other he cashes those as well uh let's
go to the comments let's go to the
comments because we we gotta get their
take we got to get their take one more
time producer Ryan talk to us how are
the Vibes in the comments yeah the
comments are still hung up on this
Cardinals Eagles talk we got Zippy
saying Cardinals money line if you like
losing that's not how you spell get rich
uh C wait says these dudes are trash
every week we're giving winners every
week I don't understand this I think we
got a winner of like winning record
every week uh Walter Plummer Eagles
minus two and a half uh the onions Chase
what a name uh Chase Edmonds anytime TD
in all caps so I don't think it gets any
luckier than that but uh those are the
Vibes guys let's uh let's keep it moving
those are the Vibes hey we turned bad
vibes into Good Vibes and we turn Good
Vibes into even more gooder Vibes so
let's transition to this next segment
any time touchdown score all right guys
it's time for you guys to tell us which
any time touchdown prop
you guys want boosted this week so fill
up those comments get those BR app
fingers going and uh let us know Ryan
talk to the people tell us
what's going on bro should we pull up
the full screen actually pull up the
full screen for Ryan
it's all right let's see let's see these
odds first off remember to keep dropping
your locks in the chat we're going to be
grading them at the end of the show so
keep giving us your locks uh but all
right let's hit this Nick Chubb minus
135 I said it earlier we go back to the
classics I mean he cashed the squad ride
last week he's only minus 135 this week
we got Stefan Diggs at -110 I feel like
any time you get Stefan Diggs at that
number why not Cooper cup uh taking a
trip to Diggs Island this afternoon I
don't minus 140.
that should minus 140. guys that should
be plus 600 at least he's not he has
been good this year I'll give you I'll
give you that he's a lot better this
year phenomenal is the word I would use
but I'll settle for good uh and then
Justin Jefferson Justin Jefferson minus
110. he captured me last week I hope he
does it again this week
um not plus money this time they may
have learned their lesson and then James
Robinson to round it out at number eight
minus 115. so uh again drop us your
locks to the chat guys what are you guys
riding with
honestly after you just told me who's
going to be Garden Cooper
staying on the mainland and he's going
on a vacation today yeah so uh I like
Cooper cut
oh man you like losing money Greg
I like cup as well uh again producer
Ryan look up a stat that favors a pick I
like but like cup is on Pace for like
250 Targets this year like it's
absolutely insane they don't have any
other receivers they're just throwing
them a million times over he didn't
score last week uh I think he finds uh
finds the end zone this week oh you're a
big Stafford guy
they throw it to him 20 times again
literally he's on Pace for a billion
Targets this year and maybe not
literally a billion but close to it who
do you guys think has more catches today
Trayvon Diggs or Cooper cups
[Laughter]
cooper cooper cup Cooper cup
minus 12. what's the audience what's
what's the comments talking about okay
uh we've got Vinnie back in the chat
saying Austin Eckler anytime touchdown
uh Mark the onions is back Marquis Brown
gets a TD lock that in right now M Kent
Derrick Henry all day sprinkle on two
TDS Mike Ritter
tough tough day for Mike Ritter he's
coming off his Cardinals losing he's in
the chat and he's given us the Vibes
with all caps Diggs sideline touchdown a
little uh Joe Buck back there Ryan on
that note on that note right there bro
let's just give us a pic from the
audience what are you seeing uh and if
you don't see too many of the same
person just just put your foot down and
tell us who we are riding with this week
we got dicks it's all dicks I now again
they could be talking about Trayvon
Diggs because you know it's his day but
all I see is digs digs digs so should we
boost that
why not
let's do it a you guys see it it says
minus 125 right there let's do some
magic because we are boosting that from
minus 125 to plus
140 yes we here we here is the only ones
that is doing that for DraftKings uh
Sam talk to me talk to the people make
it quick brother I need a quick pick who
is your TD score for this week who's you
rocking with uh that's cop I kind of
explained it earlier so I'm just going
to use this time to say I think we need
some like animations when Greg comes in
and gives the Boost it gives them give
them like a wizard hat or something and
let him like you know change it we need
something
it's a great great moment because we
here are the only ones that's doing that
for DraftKings uh Sam took Cooper cup
I'm rocking with Mark Andrews keeping it
super short and sweet had a not a tough
game last week had a tough game last
week looking for him to bounce back no
basement in the lineup
feed Andrews feed Andrews Lamar Jackson
and if you want to Parlay all threes you
want to Parlay all three mine Sams and
yours DraftKings will boost it by 25
percent
yes they will boost it by 25 uh check
out socials for the links to the Boost
all right guys
it's my favorite time of the show there
is a rookie there's a rookie that's uh
taking on the Buffalo Bills today he
plays for the Pittsburgh Steelers not
sure if you guys are familiar with him
but his name is Kenny Pickett Kitty
Pickett is taking on those Buffalo Bills
today and he's having his first career
start he's having his first career start
so I think the theme of this segment
guys is a rookie is going to be a rookie
so that's what we're betting on we're
betting on a rookie to be a rookie I
need everybody drop your favorite Kenny
Pickett locks in the chat because
we need your help we need your help and
we will grade those at the end of the
show Ryan pull up the parlay ticket so
the people can see
how we are dissecting Kenny Pickett
today this is called a rookie being a
rookie invite and Sam Ryan what I mean
by that what I mean by that my man came
in last week
he threw three interceptions not one not
two not three but that is a rookie being
a rookie so with that being said in his
first career start we're just connecting
Dots here I got one interception for my
man Kenny Pickett one plus interception
for Kenny Pickett and we're riding with
it because a rookie is going to be a
rookie next Sam usually you know when
rookies go out there they scored their
first touchdown they they eat it's their
rookies it's his first career start so
here we go I think he did not get it he
did not get a throwing touchdown last
week he got two rushing touchdowns last
week's this week I see him getting a
throwing touchdown not I mean I don't
know maybe two maybe three but I just
want one I just want one Ryan all I need
is one now Sam
follow me here audience you guys follow
me last week he threw for about 120 Ryan
fact check me there I believe it was
around 120 but he only played a half
guys he only played
the second half of the game
my man threw for 120. all I need is 175.
all I need is for the rookie to go out
there and be a rookie that's it that's
it this this this parlay is literally is
made for a rookie to be a rookie all
right uh Ryan talk to me
first off fact check me did you fact
check me on his yards last week I did
fact check you but there's no reason to
you were correct it's 120 yards 100 see
I did I did my due diligence I did my
studying before the show because I was
in the lab before this I was in the lab
for this rookie being a rookie parlay
Ryan talk to me about the comments how
are they feeling yeah so Danny Tavares
is jumping in here it's saying you don't
don't just settle for one interception
go with two uh Sugar Shane saying pick
it over half interceptions is a lock
it's not a lot of Kenny picket loving
here uh DJ Fitz Kenny Pickett anytime TD
Plus 500.
that's juicier than the entire parlay
Plus 500. he did score two last week two
rushing touchdowns last week Sam two of
them that might be
the thing I like most about this parlay
is I I wouldn't be surprised if you
maybe get off to a slow start in the
first half because Sears are going to be
like we're gonna run the ball through
rookie but they're gonna get crushed by
the bills and in the second half they're
gonna have no other option but to just
throw it all over the field he's gonna
force a pick he's gonna throw a
touchdown garbage time uh I love this
player for you Greg this is cashing I
will say Anthony Pittman jumped in here
and said basically the same thing as you
Sam you said Steelers will be behind so
he'll be passing a lot yup hey hey all
we're trying to do don't get discouraged
if he has like 80 yards in half it's the
second half where that's going to cash
hey all we're trying to do here is
connect the dots man that's all we're
trying to do is connect dots let's pull
up the ticket so we can show you guys
and uh we need to pick you guys are
saying that he's going to throw multiple
picks why don't we call this the picket
pick parlay slash rookies will be
rookies that's what we're gonna call
this one uh but there it is three picks
plus 195. rookies hey at the end of the
day I'm gonna say this one more time and
then we're gonna end it
rookies will be rookies and we're
looking for my man Kenny picking on his
first career start to go out there and
be a rookie All Right Moving On Moving
On Ryan Sam
over under all right
we're gonna put up some props we're
gonna put up some props from DraftKings
and we're gonna talk over or under I
need you guys everybody in the comments
get on there go give us some player
props from DK and tell us uh which one
is your favorite drop them in the chat
Ryan pull up those odds for us rather
pull up those odds for us there they are
all right Ryan
so five most bet player props just so
happy to be quarterbacks it's a
quarterback League we throw the ball a
lot so Josh Allen passing touchdowns
over one and a half minus 200. Patrick
Mahomes passing touchdowns over two and
a half plus 130. Rogers passing
touchdowns over one and a half if you
bet it you already cashed it Justin
Herbert passing touchdowns over one and
a half minus 150 uh and then Joe burrow
passing touchdowns on Sunday night
football against the Baltimore Ravens
over one and a half minus 155. that
that's a pretty surprising list I'm
surprised that the general public would
take the most famous quarterbacks and
bet all they're over to square
touchdowns I would not have guessed that
though that that would happen it's not
what the public usually does I'm
surprised Jimmy G and his odds are known
here they might be like plus a thousand
but uh all right guys Patrick Mahomes
coming off an insane game against the
Tampa Bay Bucks two and a half plus
money how are you feeling about that
over or under
it's juicy I mean it's it's pretty juicy
uh I think at plus 130 I'm I'm intrigued
by it I I can't lie Greg what's your
take
Ryan tell me who he's playing the Las
Vegas Raiders and the switch everybody
everybody know how I feel about the
Raiders in that defense you can go on my
Instagram and go one of my posts it'll
tell you the Raiders in that defense
defend not impress me at all and Patrick
Mahomes is on my fantasy team I am
riding
all right uh uh let's see we got another
one Chris olave
over under five and a half receptions
I like Crystal a lot and Crystal always
I like them too I'll take you over there
it's a plus model for there plus money
plus 120. sweet uh Tyreek Hill with
Teddy 2 gloves over under 73 and a half
receiving yards
oh that's an interesting one that's an
interesting one
wow
I'm gonna say over but I wouldn't be
surprised if he
gets a lot of damage like and if they do
like some jet sweeps and he gets a lot
of damage on the ground
um but all it takes is just one one deep
pass with him
um yeah hey that's what I'm saying Sam
it literally just takes one with Tyreek
Hill and his speed so
73 and they're probably gonna run a lot
of screens and he can make guys look
silly so
uh all right Teddy C is jumping in here
and saying Kenny Pickett 0.5
interceptions we just talked about this
are you both did he just turn the show
on yeah I think he might have you're
both oh uh
okay we were riding rookies will be
rookies brother rookies will be rookies
and that's what we are riding uh drop
your picks in the chat drop your picks
in the chat and Sam and I will great
them me and Sam is going to grade them
Ryan what kind of picks are we getting
from the comments
so far uh well I have another one over
under if you guys want to jump in here
real quick since we talked about the
last one Danny Tavarez Jalen hurts
one and a half touchdowns
passing or passing touchdowns I'm sorry
under
we are we we are on the Cardinals today
uh maybe we'll get one on the ground but
uh I'll say like maybe one on the ground
one through the air but two is a two is
a lot especially with how they sort of
uh run their offense I'm taking under
there for sure they're on the hype train
they're on the hype train they're gonna
hide paid the hype I think they're gonna
get humbled this week cool all right
real quick before we jump into grading
their bets our friends at DraftKings uh
are giving away a two-night stay at
Foxwoods uh Casino Resort and a 250
dollar fine dining
uh voucher so if you are in the
tri-state area and you are interested
jump in the comments let us know we're
giving that away but for now we're
grading defense
so
Let's Get It Started uh
Trevor Lawrence teach from DJ Fitz his
passing yards over now would it have
been helpful for DJ Fitz to have dropped
the number of passing yards I don't know
what the number is it would have it
would have been helpful uh but he just
said passing yards over so all right do
you guys think Trevor Lawrence goes off
today
Ryan say see okay uh one because I don't
know the number and two uh Texans sneaky
good defense so uh I'll say it under or
I'll say C because uh incomplete we need
like an incomplete grade I'm gonna go C
minus because my man did not complete
his assignment you have to complete the
assignment yeah I don't have him he he
halfway completed the assignment that's
why he's getting the C minus but you
have to complete the assignment and tell
us the number okay uh more Raiders
loving here Jay Gonzalez Josh Jacobs 100
plus yards rushing
it's not bad it's not bad I think your
only concern there is they fall behind
too much and have to abandon the ground
game but I do think the Chiefs can uh be
run on a little bit uh so yeah actually
I'm changing to a C I'm with Greg I'm
actually on C because they're gonna fall
behind Okay yeah I'm I'm right there
with you Sam I think they're going to be
uh chasing the Chiefs and when you're
chasing you usually throwing the ball
rather than running so all right Al
Mendoza Kyler Murray anytime touchdown
[Music]
what are the odds
that's a good question give me a second
yeah next time you give your pick just
just do us a little favor drop the odds
in there
um we can't have producer Ryan looking
up everything on the spot but I got two
ideas for the chat
I'm everywhere yeah you are everywhere
uh I do like I like a little Kyler game
today uh and he kind of has to like the
only success they've had throwing the
ball this year has been when he's just
doing you know that sort of old school
Russell Wilson scramble magic throwing
it running it so uh I like Tyler today
Sam we're right here Greg and Ireland
because I was literally going to say the
same thing like when Kyler goes they go
so
I think they're in Tyler's ear telling
them that he has to go so we'll see
today it's uh it's plus 2 15 on
DraftKings so you got some nice odds
there
uh trig away says Dalvin cook over 75
rushing yards
against the Bears
it's tough it's tough
um see I don't I don't hate it I don't
love it they will probably be up and be
running the ball a lot
um but the Bears have been sneaky good
on the ground uh I think backtrack me
there that could be wrong
um I think they've been pretty decent
against the Run
um but yeah I don't know don't hate
don't love
okay uh we'll do one more and then we'll
give away the Foxwoods uh Ivan Ivan
Arata Alvin Kamara coming back from
injury to score touchdown against the
Seattle Seahawks anytime TD all right
yeah I like that
I like that one well I'm gonna let Greg
Cook here he's got something
here we go I'm gonna give that one the a
plus plus like similar similar to what I
just said about Kyler Murray when
camara's going that offense is clicking
and I think him coming back
little bit of fresh Lids you know a
little he's been off a couple weeks with
some fresh legs I think that they are
going to try to get him going so I like
that I like that one a lot
minus 130.
I like minus 130. yeah you would have
liked to see plus money you would have
yeah but hey parlay that's a leg
that's also minus 130 it's not terrible
so it's it's not you can drop something
on that and see a little I mean you see
a return yes we're not Union shame and
we're not doing none of that here Ryan
you have that uh that voucher is anybody
in the comments you seeing catching your
attention oh for sure we got Kevin
Morgan in here in all caps screaming
that he's in Connecticut and he wants to
go so Kevin Morgan congratulations you
ask and you shall receive so take a look
at your DMs we'll send you the info uh
congrats on that so that's the Foxwoods
thing guys
Kevin Morgan congratulations you are
going to Foxwoods
Sam Ryan it's been fun uh let's get on a
body here let's go continue to watch
that game we gotta finish my parlor we
gotta finish watching the first leg of
my parlay cash that Packers minus two
and a half and I'm pretty sure you guys
got some bets on it and you guys at home
also got some bets on it it's NFL Sunday
we're all hyped let's all go win today
for great I'm Greg Ivey for Sam Richmond
Ryan producer Ryan
we are out peace
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]